the wreck of the Costa Concordia for
more than 900 days the cruise ship lay
just off the Italian coast its presence
transformed life on the island of giglio
I've come here for the last days before
it gets towed away for scrap
a small hotel overlooks the rack it
belongs to Catalina Pellegrini and she
has vivid memories of the night in
january two thousand twelve when the
ship is arif cuando [ __ ] capital city to
do when she finally understood what all
the noise was she walked down to the
harbor she explains hey someone that you
soon moral orel saw when the first
rescue boat arrived with survivors she
asked how she could help the policeman
asked everyone to bring blankets so she
did and she took in as many people as
possible casiple persona was serially
there were 4,200 passengers on board 50
of them stayed in her hotel that'll
nostril let door she gave the survivors
dry clothes showed them to their beds
help them get ready and put them to bed
yab yum with his teeth it she says she
has one especially painful memory of
that night two and a half years ago it's
about a German woman but then Catalina
has to break off her story that 32
passengers died in the disaster then
after the tragedy the long cleanup began
that has at least brought business to
the island Katerina's hotel has been
booked up ever since IBM all say she has
six rooms she explains and all of them
are taken by the salvage company Titan
most of the guests are engineers and
staff working on the Costa Concordia
operation he loved would appear de la
Concorde yeah after the disaster some
300 specialists from all around the
world descended on the island Caterina
Pellegrini has collected newspaper
cuttings about the people who stayed
with her they've almost become part of
the family did you so Lucy who would a
QP on 0 when the ship leaves Giulio
should be crying all day she admits with
joy because the racks gone but also with
sadness at the guests shall lose
they include Dutch engineer yarn ball
halt he's the youngest specialist
working on a project he went freelance
after leaving University and quickly
ended up on Julia I'm here for two years
now on this amazing project it's so huge
and it's an honor to be here because
where these are one of the largest
Salvage jobs wreck removal jobs ever
been done in the world I'll be following
yarn over the next few days just before
eight he sets off for his workplace I
Hulk 290 meters long 35 meters wide and
weighing 115,000 tons the general idea
is that we want to remove the wreck
entirely by use of 30 sponsons and the
sponson is actually a guy antic steel
box it's like a 11 stories high it's
like like like like a flood or tower the
salvage company has offices in a nearby
hotel here Yan tells me more about the
challenge has team faces he uses the
ship's plans to show me how the wreck
has been refloated the operation is in
the final stage in just a few days the
vessel is due to be towed to Genoa
personally beginning we started the
power the hustle right they build a
platform underneath
then they use those gigantic pool of
food the pestle straight fantasy Harris
on the next faces they insult although
the starboard sponsors inside of the
Concordia and then the first step is
that they lowered it down and press the
water out of it so that explains
sponsors create buoyancy so that the
entire wreck it flows the white tanks or
sponsons were welded to the side of the
ship then compressed air was pumped in
and slowly the Concordia began to rise
they used swims-a-lot the box to put it
more is what and when it's entirely east
then we will I give the final water then
we get fine Paul and then on the
computer screen that all looks perfectly
plausible but can it really be done are
the engineer sure that the cost of
Concordia will soon begin its final
journey yeah the engineer who put up the
design together they take a uterus and
indeed has never done before but we all
believe in the plan and then I'm happy
to be in this team say I'm little bit
proud of it too to be part of it and we
all play this it will happen here over
the last two years 500 people have
worked on board the Costa Concordia on
deck underwater closely supervised by an
expert team
the Italian authorities constantly
monitored the water around the wreck
site very soon their work is said to
come to an end it seems hard to believe
yawn Valhalla has to board the vessel
again to work there he even had to take
a climbing course it's quite danger
because there are a lot of cranes and
people are welding there we have to
climb sometimes from from one room to
the other room or climb on the huge
sponsons and to work under harsh
conditions the project has had its own
tragedies one diver was killed in the
operation scary mattia it's itchy you
risk with we are willing to take it to
remove the vessel it's actually part of
the job fella that's how it is danger
stress and fear are all part of the job
today Yan has to check the position of
the air tanks on the hull they need to
be fixed precisely so the towing can go
ahead for safety reasons I'm not allowed
to come along I wait unsure
when yarn returns after a 20-hour shift
he has bad news one of the sponsons you
cannot fix it the good imposition and
the level is still still wrong so we
have to lower it down a little bit and
yeah if this gonna take to do long we
won't make it with just a couple of days
remaining time is of the essence and the
stress is showing this job could be the
start of a career for young you need
things to go well that's quite a burden
to to be responsible for food is for
this operation of course you have at the
entire team but still it's it's how you
feel responsible for fully work you are
doing so take is very serious Wally on
catches up on some sleep his team step
up their efforts in the end they manage
to correct the position of the tanks and
raise the wreck higher yan here's the
news from his friend and colleague David
fish an engineer from Belgium he's also
been on a project since the beginning at
the moment we are in the final stage of
the of the project was still going up
with the ship and try to reach a draft
of between 18 and 19 meter and also the
last preparations to tow the ship to
Geneva it's a point tricky tricky job
but all became too good and and yeah we
all quite nervous so we are working here
12 or 14 hours a day sometimes longer
sometimes we we work day and night just
to finish the job the two men have to go
out to the ship again if things go
according to plan it'll be their last
time this day will be crucial if the
rank is to be towed away on time
yarn and his colleagues will stay on
board for the next 24 hours
and brings to the we have to be inside
the control room on the vessel because I
such love things are going on at the
moment example we watch on the screens
we see the video data come in and if I
saw if there is a problem we can
directly maintain I wish them good luck
once again I'm not allowed on board for
safety reasons a special control room
was built on the wreck itself for the
salvage operation this is where all the
images and data come together where all
the work on the operation is monitored
it's an incredibly intricate set up just
one mistake could ruin years of work the
engineers have worked to the night jaan
Val hot is exhausted after such a long
shift but the job is done yeah actually
have you seen we lifted the vessel the
lobster a couple of meters so actually
ready for the torch now leaving the
direct for the last time it's quite
quite strange because you're actually
leaving home a little bit because it's
your office you live there 12 hours a
day and it's it sounds strange but it's
also a little bit yeah becomes our our
own world and now we are leaving it at
long last Giulio can celebrate the
departure of the Costa Concordia the
ship is heading for general be unveiled
it's a proud moment
really really strange it's almost unreal
that we did it and that the wreck is now
we're floating again and it's so so
unrealistic so unreal but still it's
true and we did it we did this after two
years of hard work yawn still has to
come to terms with his team success for
me to it's difficult to believe the
people here can now begin a new chapter
after the tragedy and after the cleanup
the Costa Concordia is finally on its
way
you